this is a production of cornell
university
good afternoon everyone i am absolutely
thrilled to be here and it is so
exciting to have a chance to talk about
some of the work that i've been doing
recently since i left cornell in 2006.
and this is my first time back to campus
since then and
so many great memories come back and
it's it's really just a thrill and an
honor to be here so thank you very much
for for inviting me and and having me
here
this is the asian turf grass research
facility 70 kilometers north of bangkok
this photo you'll notice
was taken in 2008 this doesn't exist
anymore i built this and maintained it
and had seven employees but we found
although we learned a lot about turf
grass it really wasn't a very good
business because this cost a lot of
money to operate
but
it didn't really generate a lot of
revenue but in the four years that we
had the asian turfgrass center research
facility from 2006 until 2009 i got a
chance to work with so many different
kinds of grass and i got a chance to see
how they performed
and now i travel around a lot and i see
grasses in so many different places
and there's
there's a big area in asia and there's
all different kinds of grasses growing
in the different places so this is in
singapore there's a grass called
broadleaf carpet grass we can go to
india this is in southern india at kodai
canal this is kaikuyu grass this is a
gar it's the world's
largest species of wild cattle and these
are a very strong animal it looks like
they'd lumber but they actually can jump
very high they're they're extremely
strong just pure muscle
in fact tigers don't attack them i've
heard that that they will take out a
tiger if a tiger would attack it
this is kikuyu grass which is a grass
that's from i believe the highlands of
of east africa originally
this is in the same state in in
coimbatore in tamil nadu now we have
seashore paspalum and you'll see a
little bit of bermuda grass is growing
there
coming in a bit of this we're seeing is
a video distortion but there's some
bermuda grass there's a weed invading
seashore pastebalum turf
there's also some footprints going
across the grass can anybody guess what
that might be
elephant footprints
so you can see the you can see the muddy
areas this course is still under
construction there's some open land and
the elephants came out and one of those
is an adult elephant and then there was
a baby elephant coming along with it so
one of
the thrilling things about my job in
addition to me being so interested in
grass and getting to see different
grasses growing in so many different
places i also get to see cool things
like elephants going across the turf
that one wouldn't otherwise see
so we go from the areas near the equator
where there's all warm season grasses
grow grasses that use the c4
photosynthetic pathway up to korea or
northern japan this is in hokkaido in
the northern part of japan now it's all
cool season grasses something similar
to what would be growing here the rye
grasses and the fescue grasses and the
bluegrasses
we can also see a bit of that in the
high elevation areas in japan this is in
a golf course in yamanashi prefecture
which is
that's mount fuji in the background on a
late summer day so there's only a little
bit of snow around the summit
and in japan it gets into the transition
zone and then much of asia is what we
would call transition zone where it can
be both warm and cool season grasses
but an an interesting thing about asia
is there's not a lot of turf grass
research
so it's this vast area of
a vast area of the world without turf
grass research
stations without people doing a lot of
research about grass and as i travel
around i'm able to learn a lot
about what is actually growing but i'm
not able to put out test plots or try
new varieties or new species of grass
because it just would not be feasible
i made this map and i marked in cornell
red
the various places that i've traveled to
but many of these places so
this is guam this is melbourne adelaide
this is mauritius
so
we go a little bit outside of asia
because mauritius is africa this is
australia
dubai in the west
and then various places through south
asia southeast asia and east asia
i've been to a lot of
a lot of places to study about grass
and these aren't just one-time visits so
for example a place like tokyo is just
marked on there once but i've been there
obviously a lot of times
and just to give you an idea of the
scale of this some of you will have been
to asia probably are from there but
last week i flew from reykjavik in
iceland to new york city and that flight
is actually shorter than the bangkok to
tokyo flight and i take the bangkok to
tokyo flight many times a year and
that's longer
than the flight from new york city to
reykjavik so that would just be from
from bangkok here up to tokyo
so
we get a huge variety in the grasses and
the question is how can we predict
what grass we would use because the
question everybody asked me what what
the the first question is what grass
should i grow and we can look at so
many of the turf grasses that were
planted in the 1990s early 2000s they
didn't work very good and i'm going to
explain a little bit later why i think
that is
but the first question what grass should
i grow how can we possibly predict that
if we aren't testing grasses in
different areas that's that's a big
question and the second main question
which i will touch on how i try to
address that
is how should we manage the grass so
once we choose the grass
how can we manage it so i'm going to
talk a little bit today about how we
might manage some of the
nutrient additions to the grass looking
at what the nutrient requirements of the
grass are
i made this little chart and i just
plotted on the y-axis is the average
annual temperature which ranges here
from 15 to about 28 degrees and then i
just listed these cities so if the
city's down at the bottom that means it
has a cooler average annual temperature
if the city's listed at the top it means
it has a higher average annual
temperature
and one of the ways that we would decide
what grass to use in in a in a broad way
would be to look at what the temperature
is
and you'll notice if you'd go to all of
these places and look at the grasses
once you get above an average annual
temperature of 20 degrees
you don't really see
the cool season grasses growing in those
areas at all
so we can basically say that the 20
degree average annual temperature is a
pretty good
cutting off point for where the the
transition zone ends and we don't
attempt to grow cool season grasses
anymore
so the cool season grasses are those
that use the c3s photosynthetic pathway
and in dallas there's it's mostly warm
season grass but there's a bit of cool
season in fukuoka
there's mostly warm season but a bit of
cool season
you know greenville south carolina
shanghai atlanta there's
people in atlanta will have tall fescue
lawns that's a that's a cool season
grass and yet they also have a lot of
warm season grass
so one way to look at it is just by the
the temperature but to look at it more
specifically it's interesting to look at
something called the growth potential
and i've there's a couple handouts left
if you're interested in this and want to
see it right now i will also post this
on my website tonight
so you can
you can download all these slides and
you'll also be able to download the
handout which has these equations and
links to additional information on it
that's
asianturfgrass.com and you can find on
the blog section of it
i'll make a new update so the growth
potential
generates a number between zero and one
that essentially tells us how close the
actual temperature is to the optimum
temperature for photosynthesis and
there's some general research that says
for cool season grasses they grow the
best and they have the optimum
photosynthesis when the average
temperature is 20. so this equation
looks a little bit tricky but there's
actually only one variable because
the gp is growth potential which is what
we're going to calculate this is a
constant this is a constant the optimum
temperature is a constant we just change
it based on what we decide our optimum
temperature is the variance just adjusts
the shape of the curve so that's also a
constant the only variable we have here
is the actual temperature so we can put
that in on a daily basis or a weekly
basis or a monthly basis
and we can calculate what the growth
potential is of the turf which tells us
how we expect the grass to grow in
response to temperature so assuming that
water is not limiting assuming that
light is not limiting assuming
that the amount of nitrogen that the
plant has in the leaf is not limiting
then the temperature will be controlling
the growth
we get this type of curve then so we've
got temperature on the x-axis going from
0 degrees celsius up to 31 and if we
look at the warm season curve we see it
starts slowly once we get to about 12
degrees or 15 degrees which is where
warm season grasses will come out of
dormancy and start growing then we see a
gradual increase until we get up to
about 25 degrees
now we get a growth potential that's
greater than 0.75
meaning the grass could grow at 75
percent or more of its of its potential
with a optimum of 31 which is what the
textbooks say is the optimum
growth temperature for warm season
grasses
now i don't let warm season grasses go
down after this i've talked to lots of
people in dubai where sometimes the
temperatures are well into the 40s and
they assure me that as long as the
grasses are supplied with enough water
they don't see a restriction in growth
and if i read about
the photosynthesis of warm season
grasses there's been some experiments
with bermuda grass where they
accidentally let the greenhouse get too
hot and the temperature was up to 40 or
above and there they actually the grass
was growing better so i think with warm
season grasses
basically anywhere in the world we don't
get an average temperature that's above
about 33 or 34. so any
any temperature that we're looking at
the we can expect the warm season
grasses are going to grow better with
increasing temperatures for cool season
grasses it's a bit different because now
we get a peak around 20 degrees and as
it gets above 20 degrees we'll see a
restriction in growth and i looked up
the the 30 year average weather data for
syracuse
and i calculated the monthly growth
potential based on that
so now we're looking on the x-axis
january through december
and i've plotted the monthly growth
potential based on the average
temperature on the y-axis
and
i think frank could probably tell me
if
if this is relatively accurate or not
this is predicting that the grass starts
to grow just a little bit in april it
grows relatively well by may
it has the potential to grow well this
is assuming it's supplied with water and
nothing else is limiting
no other limiting factors and it looks
by october it's it's really slowing down
in november it stopped
it so that's what it shows for syracuse
i i think based on my time here this
seems about right to me and this is very
interesting you'll notice we're getting
a number from zero to one
so we could actually look at that as a
fraction we could multiply that times
something such as
the nitrogen fertilizer rate so we could
say
and i'll talk about this at the end of
the presentation we choose a maximum
nitrogen rate that we want to apply
and because the the amount of nitrogen
in the leaf tends to be relatively
constant
then the growth rate of the grass is
going to be using nitrogen at a rate
that's proportional to the growth rate
so we can supply that nitrogen and we
can make sure that the grass is not
limited in nitrogen at the times when
the temperatures are at an optimum for
photosynthesis so this will lead to
theoretically an optimal
photosynthesis
for the grass let's add in a
city where it's hotter let's add in
shanghai onto this chart and you'll see
it looks quite different so now instead
of just looking at the overall
temperature we we're looking at it in a
little bit more detail by calculating
the growth potential on a monthly basis
and shanghai now is this color
the winters are a little bit warmer
in shanghai but it's still cold enough
that the grass really won't grow but
it's a month ahead in the spring you see
the march growth potential in shanghai
is pretty similar to the april growth
potential in syracuse and the
april growth potential in syracuse is
very similar to the may growth potentia
i'm sorry the april growth potential in
shanghai is very simple similar to the
may growth potential in syracuse but
then after peaking in
may in shanghai it comes down again in
june july august and september because
it's too hot in those months so there's
a lot of photo respiration going on and
the the
nat photosynthesis is not nearly as good
so the problem with cool season grasses
in in
high temperatures is is
largely a problem of photorespiration so
the
photosynthetic
system is not working so efficiently
so
and then in the autumn shanghai
it can grow well again and then it
plummets in the winter so i find it very
interesting to look at the growth
potential to look at
the detailed way that different grasses
may grow in in different locations
but there's something else going on
besides the temperature this is bermuda
grass turf mode at 12 millimeters and it
doesn't look right you see this picture
is pretty dark and there's actually not
grass completely covering the surface
here 12 millimeters is a pretty nice
mowing height that's a half inch we
would expect if this grass was growing
in miami florida or atlanta georgia this
photo was taken in september i was just
here a few weeks ago and there's algae
growing in between the leaves
if if this grass was managed in the same
way in atlanta or in miami or in
jacksonville we would have a dense
turf that completely covers the surface
but what we see in asia is bermuda grass
has a rather rather open canopy it gets
invaded by weeds this is
at rhoda island which is just north of
guam in the northern marianas this golf
course this is a golf course fairway it
was planted to bermuda grass but now
it's completely weeds there's very
little bermuda grass left
and
that's what happens when you don't apply
herbicides to bermuda grass in that
climate
it the grass just gets overtaken by
weeds this was a couple weeks ago in
bangkok this is a bermuda grass golf
course putting green
and around the outside is manila grass
soyamatrela
and over
about i think this green was planted
about 10 years ago
the
zoysia has encroached almost 2 meters
in in 10 years but what we tend to see
in the united states they apply
herbicides onto zoysia grass to keep the
bermuda grass from encroaching i visited
a golf course in memphis
in april and they had had to do a
tremendous amount of re-sodding and they
had to use herbicides to control the
bermuda grass that's encroaching into
the zoysia but in asia we see something
completely different we see zoysia
overtaking bermuda and we see bermuda
not growing very
well so
the the
factors affecting growth are not only
it's not only the temperature we need to
consider the temperature but there's
more to it and i want to show now
something that i think is very
interesting it's quite a difference
between
asia and north america in general so
i've put a link to this website this is
climate.asianturfgrass.com
and
i've got some interactive
charts here
that that have normal climatological
normals weather data embedded so i want
to choose here let's look at a couple
cities we might be familiar with let's
look at
hilo hawaii which is on the big island
let's look at honolulu hawaii
and let's look at
miami in
florida and i'm going to plot time on
the x-axis
and i'm going to plot the average
temperature
throughout the year on the y-axis and
i'll click here on trails
so that it will show the mark
and we'll just click play
see miami is a bit cooler in the winter
miami's the the kind of greenish one
here
i'll speed this up
you can see the temperatures are
relatively similar it goes down to about
20
comes up just a bit over 25 during the
summer and then miami comes down to be a
little bit cooler
in the
in the winter so the the temperatures
are quite similar but there's a big
difference how many people have been to
hilo
how many people have been to honolulu
if you go and look at the grasses
you will find if you walk out of the
hilo airport there's palm trees with
manila grass growing around them and if
you go to honolulu you will see a lot of
bermuda grass growing so those grasses
even though it's very close
geographically
it's different species of grasses
tending to grow in a in a wild or
relatively low maintenance type of
environment i'm just going to change the
y-axis now to sunshine hours and you'll
see hilo separates now so miami and
honolulu
on average have about 200 to 300 hours
of bright sunshine per month this is not
day length this is bright sunshine hours
which is measured when the light
intensity is greater than 120 watts per
square meter or something i'm not quite
sure on that that unit helo however has
on average maybe 150
hours per month of bright sunshine
and
so that means it's considerably more
cloudy
and that means there's less light
available for photosynthesis and if we
model photosynthesis an easy a simple
way to model photosynthesis
is say that it's equal to
the the light times the temperature
times the amount of nitrogen in the leaf
times the water availability so you put
an index of zero to one for every one of
those
main factors and then just multiply them
and so
if if the light was zero for instance it
would cancel out having an optimum
amount of water optimum amount of
nitrogen and optimum temperature if if
it's completely dark and you have no
energy you won't have photosynthesis
likewise if there's no water you won't
have photosynthesis despite the fact
that you could have
an optimum temperature optimum nitrogen
and optimum
light availability
so
in in managed turf grass systems
we can usually control the water a bit
because we have drainage systems and
because we have irrigation systems so i
just drop i drop water out of the
equation because that's something that
we theoretically can control we can
control it and because we apply nitrogen
fertilizer we can very precisely control
how much nitrogen is in the leaf so that
means i also drop that out when i'm
looking at at how
these factors may influence
photosynthesis so what we're left with
is temperature and sunshine hours so i
think it's awesome instead of plotting
time versus sunshine hours or time
versus
the
optimum temperature i like to plot
sunshine hours and temperature against
each other and now we'll get a circle
that describes the area on this chart
the the
that's circumscribed in one year so i'll
show you how this looks so let's just
we'll simplify this we'll just look at
honolulu and hilo
so now on the x-axis we're looking at
the temperature throughout the year on
the y-axis we're looking at sunshine
hours
and we
we're it draws a circle around it so
this combination of temperature and
sunshine hours on this scatter plot is
what the growing environment is at
honolulu the growing environment at hilo
has no overlap with honolulu there's not
a single day in the year when on average
the combination of temperature
and sunshine hours is the same because
there's no overlap there's not a single
day in the year
and
i i think this is interesting to apply
also to places where i've never been
like rio de janeiro because they were
going to choose what grass was going to
be planted on the golf course in the
olympics which in the turf grass
field that was kind of an interesting
thing and
i looked up the data
and i thought it's interesting that rio
rather than being similar
i'll show
i'll show you miami
we'll get rid of hilo
let's draw miami here
so to make this fast i'll just drag it
across
so here's here's the circle that miami
circumscribed so it goes down to about
19 degrees at the coldest it goes up to
about 28 degrees at the warmest and on
average there's always between 200 to
310 sunshine hours per month that's the
growing environment in miami and a lot
of
a lot of turf grass or certainly golf
people in the united states they think
they seem to think that warm
season grasses are kind of like if it
works in florida it's going to work
someplace else
however i would say if you
just because the temperature is the same
that's interesting but if you don't have
the light the photosynthesis is going to
be completely different if we draw rio
on here now
you'll see there's also zero overlap
with miami
so now
rio's in orange
miami is in
green
and you can see there's not a single day
in the year
in
in which on average the temperature
combination and the sunshine combination
is the same at rio and at miami
and
even though the temperatures are almost
the same it actually gets colder on
average in miami and it gets a little
bit hotter on average in miami than it
does in rio but the sunshine hours are
considerably less in real so that would
tell me
maybe the grasses that work in miami
would not necessarily work at rio and
what's interesting is is the grasses are
similar to the grasses at hilo
so
we'll see a huge amount of overlap here
now helo's in yellow rio's in orange
so we draw these
it's real they completely overlap
hong kong will overlap also
hong kong i think is in blue now
these charts they're interactive and
they're hours of
fun it's like video games
video games for turf turfgrass
scientists so you can see
hong kong
completely encircles both hilo and
rio and
i guess it's a good thing that i've
traveled to so many of these places some
of these places i've not been to
but i've traveled to enough of them to
have
and study the grasses and i'm pretty
confident that if you have a certain
type of
species combination growing in one place
probably an area with such a similar
climate is going to
going to see
similar grasses performing well
so when you say you're looking at the
grasses you need to
tell everyone that picture of you with
the flip-flops in the cornell shirt is
where you go look you're just not
looking out horses
yes i like to look in the wild and i
like to look on low maintenance
maintained turf areas such as cemeteries
parks
and and in the wild and hiking climbing
mountains
and and just see what's growing there's
an excellent example in thailand at a
place that's called maraca
tayawan palace
for short we just call it the love
palace it's uh about two and a half
hours drive from bangkok and it's the
most spectacular piece of tropical
architecture you'll ever see and it was
built by
the king rama the v i believe
in the early 1900's for his pregnant
wife and
it's now a museum and it has these
beautifully landscaped lawns
that under the tree right under the drip
line it's xonopus compresses broadleaf
carpet grass which is an extremely shade
tolerant grass in full sun it's zoysia
matrella
and it's mowed turf and you just don't
find bermuda grass there and in the
united states we think of zoysia matrala
manila grass as being a grass that's
really suitable for shaded environments
but in bangkok because the because of
the cloud cover that restricts the light
that
the full sun area is equivalent in the
amount of
photosynthetically active radiation
perhaps to a shaded area
to what we'd consider a shaded area in
the united states and i think this is
extremely fascinating i've made lots of
measurements about this and written
about it and in the handout i put links
to articles i wrote on this that can be
downloaded and
you can go to other sections of this web
page
for example
here where i actually estimate the daily
light integral
and this is better for viewing on the
computer instead of in the presentation
room that you can see
you can see this if you go to the
website
and you can read more about
what i do with this
so
um i
i would like to
say
quickly
let me check my notes
ah right i wrote a little bit about this
in the handout we how many people have
heard of daily light integral dli
i think that's used a lot in greenhouses
isn't it
for so daily light integral is you take
every second you measure the
photosynthetic photon flux density the
ppfd or the par the photosynthetically
actively radiation photosynthetically
active radiation measure it every second
and over a 24-hour period add all of
that together and we get a daily light
integral which is the number of photons
per square meter
per day expressed in units of moles per
square meter per day
and
that's something that is difficult to
measure all over the world but it's
pretty cool we can estimate that
pretty accurately from the sunshine
hours data there's something called the
angstrom equation that allows us
to relate the
the sunshine hours data to the actual
intensity of the light that reaches the
earth's surface in in terms of energy
and then based on that there's another
uh
it's a pretty simple conversion factor
to estimate the photosynthetic what
percentage of the total energy
that reaches the surface
is uh is photosynthetically active and
so we can actually estimate not we we
can take those sunshine hours data and
not just look at the sunshine hours data
if we want to we can estimate the the
dli
which unfortunately in turf grass we
don't really have good numbers for what
the actual requirements are but
i have some ideas based on what the
estimated dli's are in different
locations and then based on what
grass species we actually see growing
there so that's empirical research not
really controlled research in that
i
took a trip to
hilo to check this out and it's i was
fortunate as i was leaving honolulu the
top left photo is the view from the
airplane
that's it
4 28 in the afternoon
exactly 30 minutes later
i'd gone from sunshine to where i was
arriving in hilo it was now very low
clouds those type of clouds would be
blocking about 75 percent of the faux
set photosynthetically active light
the next day going back as we were going
down the runway in hilo
taxiing it was raining hard there were
low lights that's there were low clouds
that's also going to be blocking a lot
of the
photosynthetically active radiation
arriving back to honolulu it's almost
completely clear skies beautiful
beautiful sunset
and on average you can see the average
annual sunshine hours in honolulu are
considerably more that's a lot of that's
a lot of energy and remember for cool
season grasses this isn't so important
because they can't use all of the
available energy but from they can't use
all of the available light but warm
season grasses are not limited by carbon
dioxide
they're limited by how much light is
available so if we keep increasing the
light the grass would grow more and more
so as we start restricting the light by
clouds that's really meaningful for warm
season grasses it's not so meaningful
for cool season grasses and because most
of the turfgrass research is done in the
united states
and because most of the united states
where the turf grass research has done
seems to be
cool season areas i think this is
something that hasn't really been
explored in detail so people tend to
think that clouds don't have a huge
impact on
on how the grass will grow but it it has
a huge difference because
the weather is actually different those
charts show it when we actually go there
we see it and if we're in honolulu this
is all bermuda grass and it's just
thriving
and in hilo you it's we really struggle
to find bermuda grass where we actually
would this is zoysia zoysia matrella
manila grass we'll also find a lot of
carpet grass here the same grasses that
are growing in thailand the same grasses
that grow in south china we'll find
bermuda grass right at the base of the
trees and you think well wait you're
saying bermuda grass has a high light
requirement why would we find it under
trees
because those areas don't get mowed and
my hypothesis is or my theory is that
it's the mowing and cutting off the
leaves that disrupts the ability of the
bermuda grass to photosynthesize because
we're removing the photosynthetic
machinery in the leaves and so if we
don't mow the bermuda grass it can
persist as a weed but if we mow it it
gets out competed by the grasses that
can tolerate the mowing in in a type of
tropical environment or a subtropical
environment where there is a lot of
cloud cover
so here we have full sun the grasses
that are growing in full sun or the
grasses that in in the southeastern
united states would be considered the
shade
tolerant grasses
i want to talk a little bit about
management now
i want to talk about
a different way of going about thinking
of nutrient requirements and this kind
of builds on what i was doing at cornell
for my graduate research and
is also related to having to advise
people in so many different places and
trying to put that growth potential
model together with some good
soil test data
some better soil test data
research and recommendations so there's
five
key points here
and taken all together we come up with a
very simple equation to predict how much
fertilizer is required
i frank paid for a lot of tissue testing
when i was doing my research i i
i'm shocked looking back on it on how
much our laboratory fees were to do all
the testing but one of the valuable
things that came out of it is we
realized how the nutrient levels in the
leaves change or don't change and
in the short term we get a lot of
fluctuation in leaf nutrient levels but
the big picture is
basically the nutrient levels of turf
grass leaves tend to be relatively
constant and so we usually will have
about four percent nitrogen and about
half a percent phosphorus and about two
percent potassium in the leaves for
example so we we know basically here's
what's in the leaves so if we're going
to harvest the leaves and take them away
we should remember we know sort of
what's in them even without testing
so there's a chart that shows that some
of the elements on the x-axis
on the y-axis the percentage in the dry
matter of the different elements
magnesium for example would be about 0.2
percent
and
based on my research of hundreds of
samples based on lots of
other people's research we get this type
of general
kind of normal normal levels
number two the second important thing to
remember is that the amount of nitrogen
that we supply to the grass controls the
growth and the uptake of other nutrients
and this is validated by some recent
research in wisconsin
by
dr cousseau and others
and you can get this paper i put the
link to download this paper which is a
wonderful paper
i'm so glad they published this
this the link to this is in the handout
also
so they found nitrogen supply was the
primary determinant of turf grass growth
rate plant nutrient demand and nutrient
uptake the nitrogen uptake accounted for
over 88 percent
of the uptake of all other nutrients
and the uptake of phosphorus and
potassium were strongly related to
tissue nitrogen
no matter what the soil test levels were
which is also very similar to my
research it didn't matter what we did
with modifying the potassium levels in
the soil
the
amount of potassium in the leaves was
always at or above what we consider a
deficient level so the
the nitrogen
that the grass takes up is really
controlling this and the growth rate the
growth rate is really controlling this
so as the grass is growing more and as
we have four percent nitrogen in the
leaves and the grass is growing more and
more taking up more nitrogen it's also
taking up more potassium or more
phosphorus so
basically
what this does is allows us to sort of
forget about some of the other elements
and we can just assume
to make things simple we can just make
we can assume that
everything's present in proportion to
nitrogen
and then if we know how much nitrogen we
apply because we can use a grow
temperature-based growth potential to
predict how much nitrogen the grass will
use i showed earlier how we can
calculate a monthly growth potential
that's from zero to one
so if the growth potential is zero for
example in december how much nitrogen do
you think the grass will use in december
zero so we'll say our maximum monthly
nitrogen for cool season grass here if
it's a sports it this is very site
specific it depends on the grass species
the desired turf performance the soil
type but if it was a sports field we
might say 4 grams or 5 grams of nitrogen
per square meter per month would be the
maximum we'd ever apply
so we just set the maximum of 4
for example let's say that's a perennial
ryegrass sports field
and multiply it times zero that tells us
how much you know for december that
tells us how much nitrogen we need to
apply in december or how much nitrogen
the grass would be using in december and
then let's go to june when the growth
potential is very high the grass is
growing a lot if we don't apply four
grams of nitrogen per square meter
in that month then the gra the the the
nitrogen percentage in the leaf will go
down and the grass won't grow as well
and it won't be able to respond from
where so this is something that is a
simple way to estimate how much nitrogen
the grass may be using at any time
but remember the elemental content in
the leaves is relatively constant so we
always have a similar proportion of
potassium phosphorus
magnesium calcium back to the nitrogen
so if we just look at the nitrogen we
can estimate how much of the other
elements the grass is harvesting
the mlsn guidelines that stands for
minimum levels for sustainable nutrition
and these are new soil test guidelines
that were developed in a joint project
between the asian turfgrass center and
paste turf out of san diego
and
what this is is a new set of soil
guidelines based on the malik 3 soil
test extractant where we looked at
over 16 000
soil test
results
from good performing turf grass sites so
because they were all from good
performing turf grass sites we could say
that whatever was in the soil was enough
to produce good turf
but then we modeled the distribution and
we found what type of distribution best
fit the data in this case it was a log
logistic
distribution and so now we get the curve
and the probability density function and
the cumulative
density function and we can say now
we're at 0.1
so we're at
10 percent of the samples would be below
that 90 of the samples would be above
that and what we did is set at the 0.1
level we said that's for for these
actual real data from real turf grass
sites where the turf really was
performing well we looked at those data
and we didn't pick the median we didn't
say we want to be you know in the top 50
percent we're looking at what's the
minimum levels
for
for nutrition but all of these were from
good performing sites so we're very
confident let's give ourselves a 10
safety margin let's
let's say
10 percent of the samples were below
this so let's let's say let's pick this
as level as our as our minimum level
so these are the guidelines and this is
something that we look at as an ongoing
project we're going to continuously
update these as we add more data and
these are significantly lower than the
conventional guidelines so for example
for potassium it's 33.
there's some
penn state wants like 190. it's
absolutely impossible
if anybody's watching this at penn state
i don't understand in a sand root zone
it's impossible to have 190 parts per
million potassium and that's
it's just impossible and the
conventional guideline is like 50 75
sometimes up to 110 for potassium but if
we look at some of the latest research
it suggests that 50 or 30
less than 50. there was just a paper
from connecticut or massachusetts where
they did the
from umass where they did the long term
which was five years i think nitrogen
and potassium application and even
though they were below
the conventional guidelines they didn't
see a response to applied potassium so
that suggests it's less than 50 and
there's research from florida for
bermuda grass that suggests it's about
30. and the research that i did
suggested it's below 50. and so the cool
thing is these numbers that we generate
from the mlsn guidelines we compare it
to we compare it to other research it's
really close it's a little bit
conservative meaning it's safe but it's
it's like half or less than the
conventional guideline and it's real
close to what seems to be
good uh looking at phosphorus for maelic
iii there's some research from wisconsin
and from penn state that says maybe the
real number where we'll get deficiency
is 7 or 9 or 12. so we're at 18.
but what we're saying with the mls and
guidelines is as long as we maintain in
the soil at the guideline or above
we don't have to worry about adding that
nutrient the grass will have access to
enough of it and we only have to add
that element as
we get below
below as we approach that number
and we're making this also a citizen
science project we just introduced the
global soil survey for sustainable turf
and we're hoping that hundreds or
thousands of people from around the
world will contribute samples from their
site
in order to help validate this for a
wider range of areas and for a wide
range of turf grasses
so those levels were
warm and cool
as far as we know they work warm and
cool and if
anybody
has any better information we're very
public about this we have a facebook
page we please contact us and let us
know that these numbers are wrong and we
eventually will actually share the data
and we'll share the software we're right
we're we're working with our
software and writing some scripts
i would hope people at cornell are also
using that it's it's awesome
so we're writing scripts to to do this
so
we will share that code also so people
can can see exactly what we've done so
we're we're trying to be very open about
this
and
we look at it as just an ongoing project
where we continually make these numbers
better and better i'm sure that because
of the way we're doing this eventually
this is going to be the standard
soil test recommendation
so if we consider those previous points
mathematically the minimum nutrient
requirement can be determined be it's
very simple i'm not going to explain it
right here it's in the handout and you
can see some more examples of that in
the handout and i link to other articles
i've written where i explained it
explicitly
but basically all we need to do
is we estimate the harvest or we measure
the harvest
so we know how much of an element we've
harvested we add that to the mlsn
guideline which makes sure that we're
keeping that amount in the soil and then
we subtract the amount that's on the
soil test if that's a positive number
that's how much of that element we need
to apply if that's a negative number
that means there's that much excess of
that element in the soil even accounting
for for we're assuming we're harvesting
all the clippings and we can estimate
the
the clipping yield based on on whatever
percent nitrogen there is in the leaves
so
we
we can do that that's all explained in
the handout if you're into turf and want
to see how we can do this so
that is
something that
we just recently did in the last couple
of years and we're still
working on this but we think that this
will be the way that people
choose to fertilize if they want to make
sure that they're applying the minimum
amount of fertilizer necessary to to
create still create high quality turf
grass conditions but not apply any
excess fertilizer
so there's more information at my
website i will post these slides and the
handout
and
the handout has links to all of the
websites i went to and links to lots
more additional reading so that will be
on my blog which you can access from
asianturfgrass.com tonight
thank you very much
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu